You may be living under the assumption that
if your sexual partner is deceased, they will
no longer be in a position to increase their
biological fitness.
After all, one cannot continue to be sexually
active once one is dead.
Right?
Many frog species exhibit something called
explosive breeding.
This entails a short breeding season wherein
there is intense male:male competition for
female mates.
Often, many males will attempt to court the
same female, since the ladies are only sexually
available for a short window of time.
Adult frogs are terrestrial, but they have
sex and lay eggs in the water, so the tadpoles
are free to swim until they’re ready to
return to land.
The unfortunate part for many females is that
when vastly outnumbered by a crazy mob of
sex-crazed males they are easily crushed or
drowned.
Males are so intent of depositing their sperm
that in many cases they neglect to realize
they are killing their partner in the process.
This loss of life during explosive breeding
is an unfortunate reality for females of the
Amazonian frog Rhinellla probosciea.
Because of this, males have evolved a ‘functional
necrophilia’ strategy, whereby they promote
extraction of the eggs from the abdomens of
dead females and then fertilize them in a
post-mortem fashion.
Males will sit on top of a dead females’
back, and rhythmically gyrate her body in
order to encourage extrusion of her eggs.
Once the eggs are out, he can then fertilize
them with no requirement for the female to
be anything but the dead cadaver that she
is.
This strategy may sound appalling, but - when
push to shove- it does function to increase
the reproductive success of both the males
and females engaging in it.
Sure, such intense competition over a short
space of time can certainly lead to extreme
measures, but it may actually be their ONLY
chance at passing on their genetic blueprints.
If you want to see more animal videos, then
check out this playlist from our friends at
the Dodo.
Don't forget to subscribe and keep coming
back to Seeker for more videos.